- Hello, everyone.
Welcome to another episode
of Unlocking Lily.
It's always been
my dream to be a speaker,
which led me to quit my day job
to work and mentor under Evan full-time,
and all of you are coming along
the ride with me.
In every episode I take on
a different challenge to
really help me grow as a speaker,
so in this video I'm going to be
bringing all of you behind the scenes
in my mentoring sessions with Evan
because I learned from Tony Robbins
that success leaves clues.
I actually have a surprise for you.
I'm going to go find him,
and we're going to answer
some questions together.
I'm actually really
looking forward to this
because I don't even know
what he's going to say,
so I hope you guys enjoy it,
and I'll see you very soon.
(upbeat music)
So I finally got to Evan's building.
I'm going to go upstairs,
and record the videos for you guys.
I'm actually really excited to find out
his answers to a lot of things because
I actually don't know the answers,
so we'll see, we'll see how it goes.
It's going to be fun.
- What are we doing, Lily?
What's happening?
- Look at who it is, it's Evan.
How did we meet, Evan?
- How did we meet?
- Yeah.
- Lily started at Toronto Dance Salsa.
I didn't own it at the time
just an investor in the school,
and an instructor,
and then you were a student.
- Level six class I was your student.
- Was it the first time we met
in my level six class?
- I don't remember when I first met you.
- So neither of us remember how we met,
but it was dancing.
I try to dance salsa,
and then you left to go
to another school to perform.
- Yes.
- And then you came back to teach.
- And then we didn't really, did we,
I don't, I mean I'm sure we've danced,
and had pictures and stuff it's nothing.
It's not memorable
for either of us, okay?
- And then we had our first meeting,
which was apparently memorable for you,
but not for me.
- I bought the entire business
Toronto Dance Salsa
last year in January,
and Lily was one of
our salsa instructors.
One of the things that was important
to me is I like staying in touch with
the people on my team,
and knowing who they are,
what their ambitions are,
what their dreams are,
how I could help,
and also just outside of
just work, you know,
for most of the instructors
TDS is a part-time gig.
They have full-time jobs,
or their own business,
and then at night they're teaching
because that's when our classes are.
If I can help them along their journey,
and just better understand them
that was my goal.
Also, I was inheriting a team, you know,
I didn't build this team,
so I was I inheriting the people
who are on this team
apart from Alex who I kind of
picked to help me run it,
but everybody else was already on it,
and was hoping to have, I mean,
I knew faces and I knew, you know,
said Hi, and had some dances
that was obviously not memorable.
- At all.
- I remember we met at just above
the studio there's a movie theater,
and we had a table
just this random table
sitting outside the theater
it's kind of weird, actually.
We chatted for like two hours,
or maybe more.
- I think it was more.
- Was it more?
- I think it was like three hours.
- Three hours, anyway, the thing that
impressed me about Lily was
I just loved her vibe,
I loved her attitude,
I loved the hardworkingness.
I think I said something like
at some point we're going to
work together on something.
I think at the time you were also
you didn't know what you wanted to do,
and there was I don't know that
you saw yourself as an entrepreneur.
- Never, like never.
Never did I see myself as that.
- Right, I don't know,
I saw greatness within, and I said,
just keep me posted what you're doing,
and other ideas,
and if I can play a part I'd love to.
Something like that
without even knowing what you were
interested in because you were still
trying to figure that stuff out.
- I think I walked away feeling like
I could do more.
- What's the next question what you got?
- So the next one,
next one was our second meeting,
which was a big deal for me,
but not a big deal for you.
- Okay, there we go.
- You audited one of my classes.
- Oh, so that was another thing that
I introduced was auditing classes,
so going to a class,
and just seeing how
the instructor is doing.
Traditionally it would be
you were set up with an instructor,
and then you never get a visit,
and you never get any feedback
on what you're doing to improve.
- I was dying for feedback.
- Okay.
- I wanted to know.
- I wanted to get better
as an instructor,
and I didn't get any direction
with the exception of
maybe just my scores,
but that didn't really tell me
how to get better
it just told me that
I sat at a certain standard, that's it.
You sat through one of my classes,
and then after that we sat down.
I think you told me a lot of things
I was doing right.
- Okay.
- I don't think you ever said that
you were doing this wrong,
like there was a lot of
great things I was doing.
- Okay.
- Then there was one thing.
- Okay, that's all you remember.
- That's all I remember.
- Nice.
- I just had this one thing.
- The one negative thing.
- One negative thing.
- For feedback.
- I feel like I don't know you,
and at that point I have
known you for six years.
- Okay.
- And that's what really,
really bothered me.
At first I was really offended.
I was like, well, you know,
he doesn't know me because he didn't
put the effort to get to know me.
I'm pretty awesome.
So it was a context of the class.
You were saying that
you're not relatable to the students.
- Enough in class, okay.
- Enough in class.
- Okay, okay.
- Then you said to me
they will learn from you more
if you're more relatable,
and if they feel like they know you.
- Right, okay.
- I couldn't figure out why that
was a problem even.
- Okay, okay.
- I don't understand why relatability
was such an issue.
- Okay.
- Isn't it good not to be relatable?
- Isn't it good to be an inspiration?
- Okay.
- So that's what I was thinking
at the time,
and then it took a while.
I think it like took a few weeks,
or even months to realize
what was actually going on.
- Okay.
- But it sat with me, though, like I was
seething inside for a long time,
and then I had kind of realized,
you know, why am I unrelatable?
I try to put myself in a very ...
On a platform and I try to be
very perfect because I'm too afraid
to actually show what's actually
going on inside and that's where
all the vulnerability stuff
started coming in.
I started researching why,
and then I started
reading about vulnerability,
and listening to Brené Brown talk,
and I was just like it sucked
that I said, "Wow, that's me.
"I want to be perfect,"
and perfection doesn't exist
because I'm too afraid to do something
that is vulnerable.
- That was the start of the journey.
- That was the start of everything.
- I was in the process
of writing a book.
TDS is in the book because
it's built around family.
I was working with Alex,
and getting him
to figure out his one word,
and do all that was such a battle
at the beginning.
I briefly mentioned it to you
in one of the conversations,
and for some reason it stuck, you know,
I hit you at the right time,
or whatever, and then you jumped on it,
and you went with integrity at the time.
- Yes.
- Because of what you were dealing with.
- I think part of me trying to search
for personal development all of that
because I was searching for meaning
I wanted more meaning in my life,
and you just kind of ascended
with this idea I was like,
"Wow, I could find my purpose,"
and I think I was just ready.
I was ready to ...
- Yeah, you jumped on it really quickly.
- I jumped on it really quick,
but I was focused
on what was going on at the time,
so I picked the wrong word and then.
- So that was the other, you know,
like it's great how quickly Lily's
moving on these things,
but it was great to see her
taking the feedback,
finding the one word super quick
just makes it easier,
and when you understand what
the person's makeup is
it's easier to do everything with them.
Then I finished the manuscript.
I gave it to 30 people, local people.
It was huge, it was double
the size of this book.
You had some good feedback in there.
Then was reading the book what caused
you to change the word because before
I don't think I even
sent you an exercise.
I think we just talked about it,
and we came up with integrity.
- Yeah, we talked about it.
- Then was reading the book
what led you to change?
- I think you sent me one pagers.
- Okay, maybe like one.
- Just the exercise part.
- The exercise from the book.
- Then I came up with integrity.
- Got it.
- Then I read the book,
or the manuscript at the time.
The second word, extraordinary,
came out of a place where
I was very uncomfortable with integrity.
I was uncomfortable sharing
stories around it because
it just didn't feel right
like I did not know,
like I did not know how
to articulate my other word,
but I just knew integrity
was not right for me.
We had a meeting.
- What was the meeting?
What was the meeting?
- [Lily] Because I was concerned
about my one word,
so I had a meeting with you.
- Okay, I don't remember that at all.
Okay, and then what happened
after that meeting?
- Then we kind of worked through it,
and then I went to bed that day,
went to bed that night,
and then I woke up and then I realized
I stood for extraordinary because
I started thinking about
all the daydreams that
I used to have as a little girl.
- Somewhere along the way Lily told me
that she wanted to be a speaker.
That was your dream to be a speaker.
You saw yourself on stage.
You didn't know what your message was.
- Oh, yes, I remember.
I don't remember when it was,
but I remember this conversation,
and then you said these words,
which was really interesting,
it was good, you said,
"Don't tell me what your vision is
"because it might just come true."
- That's true.
- That's good.
- Yeah.
Do you remember what your
first expresar was?
- Yes, well, I did a few of them.
I think the first was
how to love yourself.
- So I mean I have a YouTube channel.
There's an opportunity
somebody wants to be a speaker
let's do it come on board be a guest.
I've on occasion had guests come on,
and be a part of the videos.
Alex has been on a number of times
more about him being a thought leader,
and getting his skills up there,
but he doesn't have
ambitions to be a speaker.
So, yeah, you told me your goal,
and we started to make it happen.
Why did you want to slash my car tires?
Like there was somewhere there.
- I'm not violent.
- No, you totally said,
you sent me a note
about slashing my Vespa tires.
- That was a joke.
- I gave her the exercise of writing
her credo and her bio,
so once you find your one word
you find your credo you create your bio
it helps kind of set your path,
and then she wrote it
somewhere in the bio she wrote
"I'm going to slash Evan's Vespa tires"
as a test to see if
I actually read it or not.
I do my work.
I read it.
- You read it, see.
- I read it.
- You knew it, it was a test.
- So I was looking for ways to
again help Lily on her path
to be a speaker,
so the YouTube videos was a start.
- Yes.
- Then Lily, you know, said,
"Okay, how about we run a workshop?"
It's not what we're kind of known for.
We don't do personal development
workshops, but we have a studio space.
We have students.
Even if only a couple of people show up
how about we do a workshop
talking about extraordinary,
create an extraordinary life,
and you came in and did that,
and we met a couple times
to go over the content.
I remember the first
session we had downstairs at Loblaws
going over the feedback.
- Oh, yeah.
- It kind of totally changed
the direction of.
- Yeah, because to that point I only
tested it on my husband,
and it worked.
Then when I gave you
the workshop it didn't make sense,
so I end up going back,
and scrapping everything,
which took me 100 hours
to make to begin with,
and then I went back and that week
I completely changed it,
and then I delivered it a week later.
- So we met like a week before
to go over the content,
and answer questions and ease nerves.
I think the biggest challenge was
you created a workshop around
an extraordinary life
for what extraordinary means to you.
- Exactly.
- But not allowing ...
- Not use their values of my own values.
- Right, we want to allow them
to define what it means for them
that was the difference.
I think that was the biggest difference.
I mean we ran the workshop,
and it was good.
How many people?
10 people showed up for the first one.
Something like that.
- It was good.
- People enjoyed it, good feedback,
and then from there we talked about
having potential one word workshops,
said, hey, people are
asking to do workshops,
I don't want to really do workshops,
but there's an opportunity
maybe you could do it.
We were also thinking about implementing
it more within TDS culture at the time,
so having Lily do regular
workshops from the studio.
We had a discussion remember before
saying like listen,
this has to be something that
you fully believe in and understand.
I get it, it's my message.
It has to be your message, too.
It's okay to have your own spin on it,
and your own take on it, you know,
Lily delivers it in a way
that's slightly different
than what I would do,
but you have to believe in
what's in the book,
and not be teaching something that
you don't wholeheartedly believe in.
Then you took it a couple of days.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if you read
the book again or you're listening
to the audio version or?
- I read the first portion of it.
Well, I read the book
a couple of times to that point.
I was actually really proud of myself
that I took a couple of days.
- Wait, wasn't it the first book that
you've read in like
20 years or something?
- 20, yes, it's true.
I was really proud of myself
for doing that because
originally I would have
just said yes at that moment.
I was almost sure, I was almost sure
that I was going to do it,
but I really wanted to make sure that
if it's a mission that
I want to be part of
I wanted to see that.
I took a few days and I realized that
we're very similar.
It's very important to know
what you stand for
in order to go out there, do things,
so I jumped on the mission,
and then I did the workshops.
After the workshop I sent you
a Facebook message saying
thank you for giving me the opportunity,
and then you wrote back and said,
"I have an idea for you."
Then I got so excited I actually
had a meeting that night.
- Okay.
- That I kind of put off because
I knew something great was stewing.
- All right.
- I knew there was something.
I just had a feeling.
- I like telling people I have
an idea for them,
and then let them sit on that
for a day or two and then I show up.
- No, I can't wait
a day or two, no, never.
- Curiosity is part of the process.
- Never.
- So I think I was just impressed
with the workshop.
I was at the workshop.
I didn't say anything.
People got a free copy of the book,
and I signed autographs,
and answered questions at the end,
but throughout the workshop
Lily handled everything.
It's intimidating, too, first like
that was a bigger ...
- Was it 30 somewhat people?
- 30 something people.
I'm there, too, right?
So like 30 something people.
I'm there, you know,
the author of the book
I can imagine it's intimidating
to be sitting there presenting
somebody else's material.
Then there were some tough questions, too,
which you did a great job answering.
She could have easily deferred it to me.
It's like, well, Evan, what do you think?
She just chose to answer,
which was great.
- Never.
- That impressed me.
One great thing about Lily
if it's going to make her
feel uncomfortable
then she wants to go out and do it.
It's like jump into
that made me feel really uncomfortable,
so I have to go out and do it.
It's like the default mindset,
which is good.
We met and I had this idea
to try to turn Lily into a speaker,
and make it a business,
and leaver her job.
You had changed your job
like a year ago same company,
but you kind of ...
- A couple of years ago.
- Something like that.
- I moved around and I was actually
when you approached me I was at a job
that I was pretty content with.
I was content and I didn't hate it
like I actually liked it,
so that's when you approached me.
- Yeah, so the idea is
to turn it into a business.
Turn Lily, modest speaker,
into a business.
It was one of those heart decisions
for me because at the time I mean
I had my YouTube channel,
I had my main business
it takes up a ton of my time.
I have TDS which was still growing,
and still lots to do,
and still more mentorship for Alex
before we get to the point
where we need to be.
It's like time is crunched.
Don't have the time for this,
but this is the timing.
It feels right I'm going to go.
I actually didn't think you were
going to say yes, surprisingly enough.
- Really?
- I would have put it at like 35%.
- Yeah, I would have said 35%,
but at least not yet not on the spot
like, maybe, okay, let me think about,
you know, maybe in the next six months,
a year, or something,
so that was what I was expecting
kind of going in,
but you know I'll put it on the radar,
and I'll see what happens,
but then I said to her, you know,
if she says yes,
and if it's great let's do it.
There was no regret, or anything there,
but, yeah, I was a little off
in the percentage, so.
- Interesting.
- Yeah, that was good.
- I was 100% sure.
Now looking back in retrospect
it was probably like one of
the easiest decisions I had to make,
and the rest I would have figured out
like the finances, everything else
I could have figured out.
I think that was the biggest thing
that was holding be back
was the financial part because
I've always been such a secure person,
and always had a safe job,
but I knew, my heart, I knew
there was something,
there was something
going to happen that night,
and when you showed up I knew.
I had a feeling that's why I'm like,
no, just come, just come tonight.
So when Evan
proposed this idea to me
I have a choice of working
remotely if I wanted to
I think it was.
- Most days.
- Most days if I wanted to except for
our days when we meet together,
but I decided that I wanted to be
around Evan as much as possible.
The reason for that is
I think there's like a certain aura
about you it's a believe aura.
- The camera just went white.
Look at that, look at that that's crazy.
- There is a certain aura about Evan,
and then the other thing is that
I like being earshot away from you,
and seeing how you handle things,
and deal with things,
how your thought process is,
and some of your confidence, too,
because starting out I'm just beginning.
Sometimes, I don't believe in myself
as much as you believe in me,
and having the confidence
behind it helps, too.
- So we initially set out that
Wednesdays were going to be Lily days,
so we spend Wednesdays meeting,
going over notes,
planning, reviewing videos,
talking strategy,
preparing for speeches
that kind of stuff,
and then the other days there's always,
there's always,
I mean I have something that
I do every single day,
so Monday is TDS day,
and Tuesday is my YouTube channel day,
and Wednesday is Lily day,
and Thursday is meeting day,
but there's micro moments in between
on the other days that
lead to conversations.
I took Alex, Lily,
and Edwin and Nina
to Tony Robbins in LA,
and I flew them down.
We stayed at Airbnb,
and we got tickets to see Tony's
Unleash the Power then?
- Yes.
- That was to recognize the people
who had done the one word exercise.
Alex was heavily into it
because I was meeting with him daily,
and he was living and breathing it.
Lily and Edwin,
Edwin is assistant instructor right now
training with Lily.
I had one conversation with him,
and he kind of jumped on it as well,
similar, to you, so I thought,
okay, I'm going to reward these guys.
We're going to go down,
have some fun and come back,
so that was good.
The five of us shared a house for a bit.
- It was fun.
- It was different.
What do you guys want to know?
Leave it in the comments.
So I think, one,
you want to work at a place where
you're going to learn something,
so you want to work at a place where
you're going to get the skills,
get the knowledge, get the experience
that you want to become.
I think with this you just kind of
fluked into it, you know,
like you were at TDS,
you were teaching,
you wanted to do something else,
it was a different owner.
I just happened to be in the space
that you wanted to get into, right?
So that was a lucky break.
Every time you get any kind of
opportunity you just deliver 110%.
You just do it better
than everybody else.
It's the same thing in business,
same thing for your customers,
like why is somebody going to pick you
over somebody else because
you just put in more work.
Always over deliver
on the expectations, right?
Like do way more than what
was asked of you,
and you're going to
get asked to come back.
Sometimes, that means
you'll work with people
who won't appreciate that value,
and you don't get the results,
but if you keep doing that,
if you bring an attitude
of over delivering into every
relationship that you come across,
yes, some people will take advantage.
Yes, some people
won't recognize the value.
Yes, some people won't
be able to afford your value,
but if you keep doing that
to everybody who you
come in contact with,
eventually, you'll start to
move out of your environment
to a much better one
where the answer is not
to just be cynical and say,
well, nobody ever appreciates my value,
so I'm going to always play small
for the rest of my life.
- Also, like doing something
just based on
getting the appreciation, too,
you have to genuinely love
what you're doing.
I mean the comments help.
I appreciate everything
that comes my way,
but if I just did it for
positive feedback I don't think
I would last that long
because it will turn negative,
sometimes, it will be negative,
and I would walk away.
I've been very, very lucky, though.
- Yeah, you got some good fans.
You got some super fans.
- Not much negativity, yeah.
- Super fans.
- Yeah, I've been really lucky.
- Lily wants some haters, guys.
I think that's what she's saying.
That's it.
- Wrap-up.
- Believe, Lily wrap-up.
Cue the Lily wrap-up right now.
- So I'm back filming with Evan.
I hope you enjoyed that
little bit of like inside look
in my mentoring sessions with him.
So I thought I'd share
three things that I really love
about working with Evan.
The number one thing is that
he has a genuine care
in finding out what I want to do,
and what my goals are,
and he tries to find
opportunities for me to grow,
but at the same time
when I do make mistakes,
or I don't work as hard as I should
he holds me accountable,
which is not pleasant for me,
but it's absolutely necessary
to help me grow.
- In my case I'm always trying
to look for ways to help
the people on my team,
and what their goals,
and their ambitions are.
I think being upfront,
and letting people know
like new things you want to work on.
I mean you're either at a place
where you're going to learn,
and you're going to improve,
or you're at a place that
you're just going to make money from,
so if you're at a place where
if you tell your boss
that you want to improve,
and you want to work
on these new things,
and can I learn,
and even in my own time
can I work on some projects,
and they say no, and it's consistent
like is that a place that
you want to stay at or not?
That's just a paycheck
where you want to go somewhere
they have to provide value, you know,
if Lily came on camera for my videos,
and sucked and said really bad things.
- It was pretty bad.
- Well, it was okay.
- It wasn't great.
- Yeah, she wouldn't be invited back
if it totally sucked.
- It was in the total.
- I asked Lily from Toronto Dance Salsa
to join me on this video.
The last time we filmed was pretty good.
The time before both her and Alex
didn't have their lines ready
for like the set.
- Why are you telling them?
- Yeah, because I was how is it guys?
This is an opportunity for you.
Recording videos with you takes
Christina and me
like four to five times longer,
so you have to come with
your lines prepared
like I don't need to tell you
how to do it, you know,
believe with the hand,
so there can be some
tough love, too, right?
But you need to have that stuff down.
You have to know what you're doing.
- And then the second thing that
I really love about working with Evan
is he gives me tons and tons and tons
of feedback,
so every Wednesday he and I meet
where I could get him caught up
with my progress as well as we review
my Unlocking Lily videos together.
We watch it painfully for me.
Really painful to watch
those videos over and over again,
but he gives me tons of tips,
and ideas and suggestions
where I can not only make
the videos better,
but become a more compelling speaker.
- Way more comfortable
in front of the camera
compared to when you were starting
compared to like if we go back
and watch the first one.
The ongoing challenge
to still stretch yourself
on all these videos is still to fuel
the words that you're saying like
I don't feel grow
as you're saying grow.
You're being professional,
and great and warm and not cold
because it's warm,
but you're not actually
feeling the words you're saying
you're just saying them
in a really nice friendly way.
- Also, another thing that I do
is now that you mentioned
I'm like how does grow
look like on camera that's what I think.
- Whatever helps you I mean try it.
- It doesn't help me,
so it's not working.
- If it doesn't help.
- I'm trying to get that.
I'm trying different things,
and it's not working.
- I think especially with arm movements
you want to let them
come more naturally,
so if you're feeling grow
your hands will just do
what you hands will do.
- Instead of like grow, right?
- Right.
Some people go too crazy on the hands,
and like the hands become
distracting to the points.
Some people are like robotic,
and you need to like,
okay, like breathe.
Some people are just more
naturally expressive than others,
which is okay.
You're explaining it.
The thing is you're summarizing
what you're doing and you're doing it
in a fantastic warm way.
You're summarizing it really well,
but you're not actually feeling what
you're saying that's the difference.
Does it make sense?
- Yeah, it's an ongoing.
- Sure, yeah.
- Like if I were to have
a conversation with someone
I probably wouldn't be like that maybe.
- Yeah, it's like
you get a challenge to grow,
you know, or whatever,
however grow feels like
if you're scared in the moment or.
- Yeah, then instead of me worrying
about like that doesn't look like grow.
- A lot of it will come, too,
with repetition and practice.
It's really just being,
the advice is being natural
in front of the camera.
- It's so hard.
- Which is hard, right?
So it comes with practice, more practice
it will lead to better results, right?
- And number three which is
probably the most important one
he loves to make fun of me,
he does, and it's much needed
because I'm on this trajectory,
and I really want to grow,
and achieve things.
Sometimes, I could be a little bit
intense and inside my own head,
so he lightens up the mood
by poking fun at the things
I'm doing in the videos,
which is super fun,
and it kind of puts me at ease,
and makes my environment
a lot of fun to work in.
- See your little neck,
see the neck, look at the neck,
the neck is in there.
- And be courageous.
- See that, see the little,
you did one there,
and another one there.
You did the double neck.
- It's my Scarborough coming out.
- Well,
good, I want to see
more Scarborough, right?
Like the neck,
and that's the kind of thing
like nobody will notice it,
but they'll feel it, right?
Like why is she so
like I'm feeling that,
I really feel that.
Even like this I'll do it.
I'll do it all the time.
It's very flirty Lily.
- So for my next challenge
I'm going to be filming in public
at Yonge and Dundas Square
because I learned from Brené Brown
that I need to have
the courage to show up,
so that's next week.
I really hope
I have the courage to show up,
so wish me luck,
and I hope it all goes well.
So the question of the day is
do you have one question
that Evan and I did not
cover in our video?
Please write in the comments below,
and I'll try my best
to answer that question for you.
So thank you so much for watching, guys.
I actually have
a special shout out for Mihovil.
Mihovil wrote,
"Whenever you feel awkward
"filming in public,
"or if you hear a negative comment,
"please remember this quote.
"Haters going to hate,
"potatoes going to potate.
"Now you're ready.
"Good luck, Lily."
I have no idea what
potatoes going to potate means, but
when I saw it I thought it was like
the funniest thing in the world,
so, Mihovil, thank you so much.
Every time I see this it makes me laugh,
it makes me feel so much better
anytime I come across any haters,
which I don't, but if I do
I could always think about this.
Anyways, guys,
I don't know what else to say.
Thank you so much for all the comments.
The heartfelt ones,
as well as the really funny ones are
so, so appreciated,
so thank you so much,
and I'll see you guys very, very soon.